Sometimes the plan works out exactly like you wanted. Stetson Kennedy grew up in the South, always hated the Klan, back at a time when the Ku Klux Klan was still feared. And after the end of World War II, he decided to do something about it.
有时候计划会完全按照你的意愿实现。史特森·肯尼迪在南方长大，一直痛恨三K党，当时那个年代三K党仍然令人恐惧。第二次世界大战结束后，他决定对此采取行动。
And so his great idea was to go undercover in the Ku Klux Klan. And so he moved to Atlanta, which was the headquarters of the Klan.
于是，他想出了一个绝妙的主意：潜入三K党内部。于是他搬到了亚特兰大，那里是三K党的总部。
This is Stephen Dubner, co-author of a new book that, among other things, tells the story of Stetson Kennedy. Kennedy made up a fake name, started hanging around in bars filled with guys who had, Kennedy wrote, the frustrated cruel look of the Klan to them. He played a lot of pool, drank a lot of beers, until finally one afternoon he heard what he was waiting for from a guy he calls Slim, a cab driver.
这是史蒂芬·杜布纳，一本新书的合著者，该书讲述了史特森·肯尼迪的故事。肯尼迪取了个假名字，开始在一些酒吧里混迹，那里聚集着一群他笔下描述的“带着三K党那种受挫残忍神情”的人。他打台球、喝啤酒，直到有一天下午，他从一个名叫斯利姆的出租车司机那里听到了他一直在等的话。
And Slim quickly revealed himself as a bigot, saying, what this country needs is a good Klux-ing. You've got too many of these Catholics, and Jews, et cetera, et cetera.
斯利姆很快显露出他偏执狂的一面，说：“这个国家需要一次彻底的‘三K化’。这里有太多的天主教徒、犹太人等等。”
And Stetson Kennedy said something to the effect of, yeah, but you know-- he said, my uncle Brady, he used to be a Klansman, which was true. But I hear the Klan is long gone, aren't they? And then this guy Slim whips out his Klan recruitment card and starts to put the hard sell on Stetson Kennedy.
史特森·肯尼迪大概回了句：“是啊，不过你知道——我叔叔布雷迪以前也是个三K党成员。”这是事实。“但我听说三K党早就消失了，不是吗？”接着，这个叫斯利姆的人掏出他的三K党招募卡，开始向史特森·肯尼迪极力推销。
Stetson actually plays hard-to-get for a little while, and then he joins up. He gets a robe and a hood, starts going to weekly meetings, learns the secret passwords and the secret names that the Klan has for things, which turn out to follow an amazingly simple pattern.
史特森先是假装很难加入，随后便入伙了。他拿到了一件长袍和一顶头套，开始参加每周一次的集会，学习三K党的秘密暗号和秘密代称，结果发现这些代称遵循着一个极其简单的模式。
They would just add the letters K-L to the front of a lot of things. So, the Klan's meeting place was called the klavern-- like a cavern, but a klavern. And two Klansmen would hold a klonversation. And then the officers were known as the Klaliff, and the Klokard, and the Kludd, and the Kligrapp, and the Klabee, and the Kladd, and the Klarogo, and the Klexter, and all these ridiculous things.
他们会在许多词汇前面加上“K-L”两个字母。所以，三K党的集会地点被称为“klavern”——就像“cavern”（洞穴）一样，但叫“klavern”。两个三K党人会进行“klonversation”（对话）。官员们被称为“Klaliff”、“Klokard”、“Kludd”、“Kligrapp”、“Klabee”、“Kladd”、“Klarogo”、“Klexter”，等等，全是这些荒谬的词。
Did they have a Klandshake?
他们有“Klandshake”（握手礼）吗？
They had a Klan handshake, which you would grip left hands in this limp-wristed way and wiggle like a fish a few times. And that was the Klan handshake.
他们确实有一种三K党握手礼，就是左手以那种软弱无力的方式相握，像鱼一样摆动几下。那就是三K党握手礼。
The other thing about the Klan that Stetson Kennedy found out was that they were a pretty smooth moneymaking operation. And so there were all kinds of dues. And you had to buy your robe from a certain place. And the robes were very expensive. And you could only have your robe cleaned at a certain place, because they didn't want everybody to find out about it. So it was this big racket. There were all kinds of rackets.
史特森·肯尼迪发现关于三K党的另一件事是，他们是一个相当圆滑的赚钱机构。所以有各种各样的会费。而且你必须从特定的地方购买长袍。长袍非常贵。你只能在特定的地方清洗长袍，因为他们不想让别人发现这件事。所以这是一个巨大的敲诈勒索勾当。他们有各种各样的敛财手段。
I never thought to think that, actually, you had to buy your robe from them. I just somehow thought that they all made their own robes.
我从没想过，原来你还得从他们那里买长袍。我还以为他们都是自己做长袍的呢。
Not only did you have to buy your robe, but they charged $15 for a robe, which at the time was a lot of money. And they really were just sheets with hoods.
你不仅得买长袍，他们还为一件长袍收费15美元，这在当时是一大笔钱。而且它们真的就只是带着头套的床单。
So Kennedy tried to use the information that he was discovering inside the Klan against the Klan. When his chapter was hired by local businesses to break up a union meeting or threaten organizers, he'd warn the union guys in advance. He passed along other information to an assistant attorney general in Georgia. He wrote editorials. He made speeches. At one point, he actually wanted to start a competing group that he also wanted to call the Ku Klux Klan, which in theory would have let him get injunctions against any real Klan group, on the grounds that they were violating the laws and charter of his Ku Klux Klan. He was having some successes, but it was kind of slow going. And then he harnessed the most powerful force known to man. I'm talking, of course, about radio.
所以肯尼迪试图利用他在三K党内部发现的信息来对付三K党。当他的分部被当地企业雇佣去破坏工会集会或威胁组织者时，他会提前通知工会成员。他把其他信息转交给了佐治亚州的一位助理总检察长。他撰写社论。他发表演讲。有一次，他甚至想成立一个竞争组织，他也想叫它“三K党”，理论上这样就可以申请禁令来制止任何真正的三K党组织，理由是他们违反了他这个“三K党”的法律和章程。他取得了一些成功，但进展有点慢。然后，他利用了人类已知的最强大的力量。我说的当然是广播。
And that's when he came up with this unbelievable idea. He was one day walking down the street. And he saw some kids playing this game of cops and robbers, essentially. And they were exchanging secret passwords. And it reminded him of the Klan, because the Klan meetings that he went to-- they would change the password every day, they had this secret handshake. It was all this childlike stuff. And this was right as World War II was over. And one of the biggest figures in all the media and in all the public imagination at that point was Superman in the comic books. But also the Superman radio show was hugely, hugely, hugely popular. It was on every night.
就在那时，他想出了这个令人难以置信的主意。有一天他走在街上，看到几个孩子在玩“警察与强盗”的游戏，本质上就是这样。他们交换着秘密密码。这让他想起了三K党，因为他参加的三K党集会——他们每天都要更换密码，他们有这种秘密握手礼。这全是孩子气的东西。而这正是二战刚结束的时候。当时媒体和公众想象中最大的形象之一是漫画书里的超人。而且超人广播剧也非常、非常、非常受欢迎。它每晚都会播出。
And he thought, huh, I wonder if I could somehow get the Superman radio show to do a show about the Ku Klux Klan, using this real information about the Ku Klux Klan that I have. And it could be like Superman takes on the Ku Klux Klan. Wouldn't that be cool?
他想：“嘿，不知道我能不能让超人广播剧制作一期关于三K党的节目，利用我掌握的关于三K党的真实信息。这就像超人对抗三K党一样。那不是很酷吗？”
When Jimmy Olsen, as manager of the Unity House baseball team, selected a Chinese boy named Tommy Lee for his number one pitcher, he incurred the wrath of a band of intolerant bigots calling themselves The Clan of the Fiery Cross.
当吉米·奥尔森作为统一之家棒球队的经理，选中了一个叫汤米·李的中国男孩担任头号投手时，他招致了一群自称为“火十字团”的偏执狂的愤怒。
So Stetson Kennedy started feeding them information. And they would end up doing four week's worth of nightly radio shows.
于是史特森·肯尼迪开始向他们提供信息。最终，他们连续四周每晚播出广播剧。
In a glade-- casting weird shadows over the nearby hills and lighting the sky above-- burns a huge wooden cross. Before it kneel half a hundred men clothed in long robes.
在一片林间空地里——阴影诡异地投射在附近的山坡上，点亮了上方的天空——燃烧着一个巨大的木制十字架。在它面前跪着五十名身穿长袍的男子。
In this scene, a white school kid is brought to a Clan rally by his uncle.
在这一幕中，一名白人学生被他的叔叔带到了三K党集会上。
Gosh, who are all these guys, Uncle Matt? And why are you wearing the sheets and hoods?
“天哪，这些人是谁，马特叔叔？为什么要穿上这些床单和头套？”
We're the Clan of the Fiery Cross, Chuck. We're a great secret society pledged to purify America. America for 100% Americans only-- one race, one religion, one color.
“我们是‘火十字团’，查克。我们是一个伟大的秘密社团，誓言要净化美国。美国只属于100%的美国人——一个种族，一种宗教，一种肤色。”
I don't get it. America's got all kinds of religions and colors.
“我不明白。美国有各种各样的宗教和肤色。”
When we get through, there will only be one.
“等我们搞定之后，就只会剩下一种了。”
Only one? But the Constitution says all Americans have the same rights and privileges.
“只有一种？但宪法规定所有美国人享有相同的权利和特权。”
The Constitution. Ha. We'll change that. Now be quiet.
“宪法？哈。我们会改变它的。现在闭嘴。”
And Kennedy wrote about this in his own writing, correct?
肯尼迪在他的著作中写到了这一点，对吧？
Yeah. At the first Klan meeting he went to after the show hit the air, the Grand Dragon, who was the leader of the local group-- he's trying to run the meeting. And then one regular rank-and-file Klansman gets up and starts shouting. He said, I came home from work the other night, and my kid and all these other kids had these towels tied around their necks like capes. And some of them had pillow cases over their heads. And the ones with the capes were chasing the ones with pillow cases. And when I asked them what they were doing, they said they were playing this new game of cops and robbers called Superman against the Clan. I never felt so ridiculous in all my life. Suppose my own kid finds my Klan robe someday?
是的。节目播出后，他参加的第一次三K党会议上，当地分部的头目“大龙”试图主持会议。这时，一名普通的普通三K党成员站起来开始大喊。他说：“那天晚上我下班回家，我的孩子和其他孩子们脖子上系着毛巾当斗篷。有些人头上套着枕套。系斗篷的孩子在追那些套着枕套的孩子。当我问他们在干什么时，他们说他们在玩一种新的叫‘超人对抗三K党’的警察与强盗游戏。我这辈子从来没觉得这么荒谬过。万一我自己的孩子哪天发现了我的三K党长袍怎么办？”
Stetson Kennedy was also feeding his information to big-time journalists and radio commentators-- like Walter Winchell and Drew Pearson-- who would quote things that had happened at that week's Klan meetings. And I don't want to exaggerate the effect of all this. From a Klan perspective, it wasn't klataclysmic. But it was pretty klupsetting. They didn't like being made fun of.
史特森·肯尼迪还将他的信息提供给大牌记者和广播评论员——比如沃尔特·温切尔和德鲁·皮尔逊——他们会引用当周三K党会议上发生的事情。我不想夸大所有这些的影响。从三K党的角度来看，这并不具备毁灭性。但相当令人沮丧。他们不喜欢被嘲笑。
The climax of the four weeks of Superman broadcasts comes in this scene that is pure poetic license on the part of the Superman writers. Basically, the racist uncle in the story evades capture by Superman and seeks refuge with the imperial head of the clan, who-- in this radio world Ku Klux Klan-- sees the Clan only as a money-making scheme, nothing more-- just a way to get suckers to pay dues and buy robes.
四周超人广播剧的高潮出现在这一幕，这是超人编剧的纯粹艺术发挥。基本上，故事中的种族主义叔叔躲过了超人的抓捕，向三K党的帝国首脑寻求庇护，而在这部广播剧的世界观里，三K党首脑只把该组织看作是一种敛财手段，仅此而已——只是诱骗傻瓜支付会费和购买长袍的一种方式。
Come now, Riggs. Is it possible that you really believe all that stuff about getting rid of the foreigners? That "one race, one religion, one color" hokum?
“得了吧，里格斯。难道你真的相信那些关于除掉外国人的鬼话？那种‘一个种族，一种宗教，一种肤色’的骗局？”
Hokum? Why, it's the absolute truth. We've got to save America from foreign elements.
“骗局？这是绝对真理。我们必须从外国势力手中拯救美国。”
Well, I'll be-- I thought you had brains, Riggs. But you've become drunk on the slop we put up for the suckers.
“好吧，真是——里格斯，我原以为你有点脑子。但你喝醉了我们喂给那些傻瓜的馊水。”
Suckers? Who are you calling--
“傻瓜？你说谁是——”
Our members, Riggs. The poor fish who want to hate and blame somebody else for their failures in life. The saps who believe drivel such as, a man is a dangerous enemy because he goes to a different church. The little nobodies who want to believe some other race is inferior so they can feel superior. The jerks who go for that "100% American" rot.
“我们的会员，里格斯。那些因为自己人生失败而想去恨别人、责怪别人的可怜虫。那些相信这种垃圾的人，认为一个人因为去了不同的教堂就是危险的敌人。那些想通过相信某个其他种族低人一等来获得优越感的小角色。那些追捧‘100%美国人’这种废话的混蛋。”
Rot? You mean you don't believe?
“废话？你的意思是你不相信？”
Of course not. You must know there is no such thing as what we call 100% American. Everyone here except the Indians is descended from foreigners.
“当然不信。你一定知道根本不存在什么所谓的100%美国人。这里除了印第安人，每个人都是外国人的后裔。”
Why, blast you, Wilson. You sound like a dirty foreigner yourself.
“去你的，威尔逊。你听起来像个肮脏的外国人。”
I'm running a business, Riggs. And so are you. We deal in one of the oldest and most profitable commodities on Earth. Hate.
“我在做生意，里格斯。你也是。我们经营的是地球上最古老、最赚钱的商品之一。仇恨。”
See, that's how you do it, right there. You get to know your enemy, and then you put it on the radio as forcefully as you can. We have three stories today on our radio show that do just that, with one big difference from Stetson Kennedy's story. In none of our other stories today do things work out so victoriously. In fact, in the other three stories in today's show, when people get to know their enemies, it just makes things way more complicated, and more confusing. From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, Know Your Enemy.
瞧，这就是做法，就在那儿。了解你的敌人，然后尽可能有力地把它放到广播里。我们的广播节目今天有三个故事正好做到这一点，与史特森·肯尼迪的故事有一个重大区别。在我们今天其他三个故事中，事情都没有那么圆满。事实上，在今天节目的其他三个故事里，当人们了解他们的敌人时，只会让事情变得更复杂、更混乱。来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是：了解你的敌人。
Act One, The Minister Meets the Martyr. We have the remarkable true story of a suicide bomber and her conversation with the head of the defense forces from the other side.
第一幕：部长会见烈士。我们有一个关于一名自杀式炸弹袭击者和她与另一方国防力量负责人对话的非凡真实故事。
Act Two, I Am Curious, Jello, in which two former adversaries-- punk star Jello Biafra and the government prosecutor who went after him-- sit down after two decades to talk.
第二幕：我很好奇，果冻。讲述两个昔日的宿敌——朋克明星杰洛·比阿弗拉和起诉他的政府检察官——在二十年后坐下来交谈。
Act Three, Eight Percent of Nothing. How could we do an hour on knowing your enemy without at least one story about knowing the enemy who is your spouse, sometimes anyway. Stay with us.
第三幕：百分之八的虚无。如果没有一个关于了解敌人的故事，我们怎么能做一小时关于了解敌人的节目呢？毕竟，有时你的敌人就是你的配偶。请继续收听。
Act One, The Minister Meets the Martyr. I first heard about this first story a few years ago. And I was kind of stunned that it had happened at all. It's the kind of thing that you see in movies, but it's really hard to believe that it could happen in real life. Basically, the story is this. There's a country at war. And the head of its defense establishment decides that he wants to meet with foot soldiers from the other side-- the people at the very bottom of the military-- to understand better what's motivating them. Even more incredible than the fact that these meetings happened is the fact that a reporter is there to record exactly what they say to each other at one of these meetings.
第一幕：部长会见烈士。我几年前第一次听到这个故事。我很惊讶它竟然真的发生了。这是你在电影里才会看到的事情，但真的很难相信它能在现实生活中发生。故事基本上是这样的。一个国家处于战争状态。其国防部门的负责人决定与对方的底层士兵会面——也就是军队最底层的那些人——以更好地了解是什么在驱使他们。比这些会议发生的事实更令人难以置信的是，一名记者就在现场，记录下了他们在其中一次会议上对彼此说的每一句话。
This happened back in 2002. Israel's defense minister-- their Donald Rumsfeld-- decided that he wanted to meet face-to-face with suicide bombers who, for one reason or another, had failed to carry out their plans. Israel's intelligence agency, the Shin-Bet, arranged for a meeting with two Palestinians who had set out to blow themselves up but didn't. The first at this meeting was a teenager named Rasan Stiti, who didn't seem remorseful, and who told the minister that he had wanted to die a martyr's death to help his people, to get rewards in Paradise.
这发生在2002年。以色列国防部长——他们的唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德——决定与那些因为某种原因未能完成任务的自杀式炸弹袭击者面对面会谈。以色列情报机构“辛贝特”安排了与两名巴勒斯坦人的会面，他们曾打算炸死自己但没有成功。会议上的第一个人是一个名叫拉桑·斯蒂蒂的少年，他似乎毫无悔意，并告诉部长，他想要死得像烈士一样，以帮助他的人民，并在天堂获得回报。
With the second bomber, it was much more complicated. What you're going to hear now is an excerpt from Vered Levy-Barzilai's story in the Israeli newspaper Ha'aretz from June 21, 2002, just a week after the meeting. Remember, she's writing for an Israeli audience about all this. The article was read for us by Enid Graham.
至于第二个袭击者，情况复杂得多。接下来你将听到的是维雷德·列维-巴兹莱在2002年6月21日的以色列《国土报》上发表的故事节选，就在会面一周后。记住，她是为以色列读者写这些报道的。这篇文章由伊妮德·格雷厄姆为我们朗读。
The meeting took place last week on Sunday at 2:00 PM in the detention room in the Russian compound in Jerusalem. Defense Minister Ben-Eliezer was accompanied by his military secretary, Brigadier General Mike Herzog. He came straight from a cabinet meeting, dressed in a dark suit, light shirt, and tie. The two men entered the room where the Shin-Bet personnel were waiting. The little room was too narrow to comfortably accommodate all those present.
会面于上周日下午2点在耶路撒冷俄罗斯大院的拘留室进行。国防部长本-埃利泽在军事秘书迈克·赫尔佐格准将的陪同下出席。他刚从内阁会议赶来，穿着深色西装，浅色衬衫，打着领带。两人走进辛贝特人员等候的房间。这个小房间太窄，挤不下所有在场的人。
They met Rasan Stiti, and then Arin Ahmed was brought in. She was very different from Stiti. He sat slouched in his seat and averted his gaze for most of the session, not daring to look Ben-Eliezer in the eye. Ahmed, in contrast, sat upright and looked straight ahead. Stiti was stiff. She was very expressive. He spoke only Arabic. She sometimes switched to fluent English, and occasionally used a few words of Hebrew. He spoke in a cold, monotonous tone as if he were reciting slogans. Ahmed, on the other hand, seemed much more sincere, and they tended to believe her. Ahmed impressed them as a young woman with a charismatic personality.
他们先见了拉桑·斯蒂蒂，然后阿琳·艾哈迈德被带了进来。她和斯蒂蒂非常不同。他大部分时间都无精打采地坐在座位上，避开视线，不敢直视本-埃利泽的眼睛。相比之下，艾哈迈德坐得很直，目视前方。斯蒂蒂很僵硬。她很有表现力。他只说阿拉伯语。她有时会换成流利的英语，偶尔用几个希伯来语单词。他用一种冷漠、单调的语气说话，好像在背诵口号。另一方面，艾哈迈德看起来真诚得多，他们往往更相信她。艾哈迈德给他们留下的印象是一位性格富有魅力的年轻女性。
Before she arrived here, Arin Ahmed was studying communications and computer programming at Bethlehem University. She's 20, born in Bait Zahur, outside of Bethlehem. Her father died when she was still a baby. For reasons that are not totally clear, her mother abandoned her and moved to Amman, Jordan, where she still is. Arin's aunts and uncles raised her and saw to her education.
在来到这里之前，阿琳·艾哈迈德正在伯利恒大学学习传播学和计算机编程。她今年20岁，出生在伯利恒郊外的拜特萨胡尔。她父亲在她还是个婴儿时就去世了。由于完全不清楚的原因，她母亲抛弃了她，搬到了约旦安曼，至今仍在那里。阿琳的姑妈和叔叔抚养她长大，并负责她的教育。
On March 8 of this year, she experienced another loss. Tanzim militant Jad Salem, her boyfriend of a year and a half, was killed. According to the Palestinians, he was killed by Israeli Defense Forces gunfire. Israeli Intelligence says, quote, he was apparently killed while attempting to prepare a car bomb.
今年3月8日，她经历了另一次打击。她的男友、坦齐姆武装分子贾德·萨勒姆在一年半的交往后被杀。据巴勒斯坦人称，他是死于以色列国防军的枪火之下。以色列情报部门称，引用原话，“他显然是在试图准备汽车炸弹时被炸死的。”
Arin decided to avenge the death of her beloved by carrying out a suicide bombing. She conveyed a message to this effect to a senior Tanzim militant. On May 22, Tanzim activists Ali Yusef Mughrabi and Mahmoud Salem picked her up and took her to prepare for a suicide bombing in Rishon Letzion. They introduced her to a 16-year-old boy, Issam Badir from Beit Jala. They were supposed to carry out the attack together.
阿琳决定为爱人的死复仇，实施自杀式炸弹袭击。她向一名高级坦齐姆武装分子传达了这一意图。5月22日，坦齐姆活动分子阿里·优素福·穆格拉比和马哈茂德·萨勒姆接她去准备在里雄莱锡安进行自杀式炸弹袭击。他们把她介绍给一个来自拜特贾拉的16岁男孩伊萨姆·巴迪尔。他们本应一起执行这次袭击。
Mahmoud Salem instructed Badir to blow himself up amid the backgammon tables on the open plaza. Arin was supposed to wait on the other side of the street for the people who weren't killed or injured in the first explosion to run in a panic towards where she was standing. The expectation was that she would soon be surrounded by a large crowd. Then she was to choose the right moment and blow herself up.
马哈茂德·萨勒姆指示巴迪尔在露天广场的棋盘桌中间引爆炸弹。阿琳本应在街对面等待那些在第一次爆炸中没有被炸死或炸伤的人在恐慌中奔向她站的地方。预期的结果是她会很快被大量人群包围。然后她选择合适的时机引爆炸弹。
The explosives were packed into black knapsacks. Arin said that she had already written a farewell letter to her family. She purified herself and prayed. The men explained to her that she had to pass for a young Israeli woman. So she was asked to wear Western-style dress-- tight pants and a midriff top. She did as she was told.
炸药装在黑色背包里。阿琳说她已经写好了给家人的遗书。她洗净身体并祈祷。那些男人向她解释说，她必须伪装成一个年轻的以色列女人。所以她被要求穿西式服装——紧身裤和露脐上衣。她照做了。
Then they met with Ibrahim Sarahne, Mahmoud's cousin, who explained how to get to the site chosen for the attack, and described the place for them in great detail. Sarahne transported them nearby. When they arrived, Sarahne gave Arin and Issam precise instructions, via cell phone, where exactly to stand so as to have the most lethal effect. They got out of the car with their knapsacks, and headed for opposite sides of the street as instructed. Arin stood in her position for about 10 minutes. Then she suddenly left the spot, returned to the parked car, and told Sarahne that she had changed her mind and didn't want to go through with the bombing.
然后他们见了马哈茂德的表弟易卜拉欣·萨拉内，他解释了如何到达选定的袭击地点，并非常详细地向他们描述了那个地方。萨拉内把他们送到附近。当他们到达时，萨拉内通过手机向阿琳和伊萨姆发出了精确的指令，告诉他们准确站在哪里才能造成最大的杀伤力。他们背着背包下了车，按照指示走向街道的两侧。阿琳在她的位置站了大约10分钟。然后她突然离开了那个点，回到了停着的车里，告诉萨拉内她改变了主意，不想继续进行爆炸。
The Tanzim men were enraged that she had backed out. They reminded her of the lofty status she would achieve and the great honor awaiting her in Paradise. Arin watched as the teenager ran and blew himself up right before her eyes. She again told her handlers that she wouldn't go through with it. And they brought her back to Bethlehem.
坦齐姆分子对她退出感到非常愤怒。他们提醒她，她将获得崇高的地位，以及天堂里等待她的巨大荣誉。阿琳看着那个少年跑去，并在她眼前引爆炸弹。她再次告诉她的指使者她不会这么做。于是他们把她带回了伯利恒。
Arin Ahmed is not handcuffed when she is led in to meet the defense minister. She sits at the table dressed in long pants and a gray sweater, a tall, full-figured young woman with long black hair and dark eyes.
当阿琳·艾哈迈德被带去见国防部长时，没有戴手铐。她穿着长裤和一件灰色毛衣坐在桌边，是一个个子高、身材丰满、留着长黑发、眼神深邃的年轻女子。
Ben-Eliezer, "Explain to me why you wanted to commit a suicide bombing in Israel. Was it for religious reasons?"
本-埃利泽：“向我解释一下为什么你想在以色列实施自杀式炸弹袭击。是因为宗教原因吗？”
Ahmed, "No, it was something personal. I was in distress. I was depressed."
艾哈迈德：“不，是一些个人的事情。我很痛苦。我抑郁了。”
Ben-Eliezer, "Why did you want to commit suicide?"
本-埃利泽：“你为什么想自杀？”
Ahmed, "You killed my friend."
艾哈迈德：“你们杀了我的朋友。”
Ben-Eliezer, "Was he a close friend of yours?"
本-埃利泽：“他是你很亲近的朋友吗？”
Ahmed, "Yes. We were friends for a year and a half."
艾哈迈德：“是的。我们交往了一年半。”
Ben-Eliezer, "Did you live together?"
本-埃利泽：“你们住在一起吗？”
Ahmed, "No, of course not. There's no such thing in our society. But we were friends. And he was killed."
艾哈迈德：“不，当然没有。在我们的社会里没有这样的事。但我们是朋友。然后他被杀了。”
Ben-Eliezer, "So what did you want to happen? Did you want to kill innocent Jews in order to avenge his death?"
本-埃利泽：“那你想要什么结果？你想为了报复他的死而杀死无辜的犹太人吗？”
Ahmed, "I don't know what I wanted. I was very hurt and angry. I have friends from the university who are active in the Tanzim. We get together a lot and go out together. We were sitting together one evening. And they were talking about how they wanted to organize a reprisal action against all the military actions and everything that Israel had done to them in the last months. I sat and listened. I thought about Jad. And all of a sudden, I said to them, you know what? I'm going to do a suicide bombing. And that was it. A moment earlier, I hadn't thought of anything like that. This was on a Friday. Afterward, I went home. I spoke with someone in the Tanzim, and told them that I wanted to do it."
艾哈迈德：“我不知道我想要什么。我非常受伤和愤怒。我有一些在大学的朋友在坦齐姆很活跃。我们经常聚在一起，一起出去玩。一天晚上我们坐在一起。他们谈论他们想如何组织一次针对过去几个月以色列对他们所做的一切军事行动的报复行动。我坐着听。我想到了贾德。突然之间，我对他们说，你知道吗？我要进行一次自杀式炸弹袭击。就是这样。前一刻，我根本没想过这些。那是星期五。之后，我回家了。我跟坦齐姆的一个人说了，告诉他们我想做这件事。”
Ben-Eliezer, "And what happened then?"
本-埃利泽：“然后发生了什么？”
Ahmed, "I thought they would take me to start preparing for it, that they would train me and teach me about weapons, something like that. I was sure it was a process that took several months. And then, suddenly, four days later, some Tanzim militants came and told me, we've chosen you. Congratulations. You're going to do a suicide bombing. And then some more senior people came. I was in shock. I never imagined it could happen so fast.
艾哈迈德：“我以为他们会带我去开始准备，他们会训练我，教我怎么使用武器之类的。我确信这是一个需要几个月的过程。然后，突然，四天后，一些坦齐姆武装分子来告诉我，我们选中你了。恭喜。你要去执行一次自杀式炸弹袭击。然后更多的高层人物来了。我惊呆了。我从没想过这一切发生得这么快。”
"But they didn't let me think about it too much. They told me, you'll gain a very special status among the women suicide bombers. You'll be a real heroine. It's for Jad's memory. You'll be reunited with him in heaven. You'll be with him in Paradise. And I did whatever they told me. They explained everything to Issam and me. This all happened very fast and then we set out."
“但他们没让我过多考虑。他们告诉我，你会在女性自杀式炸弹袭击者中获得非常特殊的地位。你将是一个真正的女英雄。这是为了纪念贾德。你会和他重新在天堂团聚。你会和他一起在天堂。我做了他们告诉我的任何事。他们向伊萨姆和我解释了一切。这一切发生得非常快，然后我们就出发了。”
Ben-Eliezer, "Did your family know?"
本-埃利泽：“你的家人知道吗？”
Ahmed, "No. I left on the day I wrote my farewell letter."
艾哈迈德：“不知道。我写下遗书的那天就离开了。”
Ben-Eliezer, "And you didn't feel bad about what it would do to them?"
本-埃利泽：“而且你没觉得这会对他们造成什么伤害吗？”
Ahmed, "I was only thinking about my boyfriend."
艾哈迈德：“我当时满脑子想的只有我的男朋友。”
Ben-Eliezer, "And what happened then? Why did you change your mind?"
本-埃利泽：“然后发生了什么？你为什么改变主意了？”
Ahmed, "I got out of the car. The place wasn't exactly like I'd seen on the map. I saw a lot of people, mothers with children, teenage boys and girls. I remembered an Israeli girl my age whom I used to be in touch with. I suddenly understood what I was about to do. And I said to myself, how can I do such a thing? I changed my mind. Issam also had second thoughts, but they managed to convince him to go ahead. I saw him go and blow himself up.
艾哈迈德：“我下了车。那个地方和我地图上看到的不太一样。我看到很多人，带着孩子的母亲，十几岁的男孩和女孩。我突然想起了一个和我同龄的以色列女孩，我曾经和她有联系。我突然明白了我就要做出什么样的事情。我对自己说，我怎么能做出这种事？我改变了主意。伊萨姆也有过迟疑，但他们成功说服了他继续进行。我看着他走过去，并在我眼前引爆了自己。”
I decided that I wasn't going to do it. They were very angry at me. They yelled at me the whole way back. And they also tried to send me to carry out another attack in Jerusalem. But I had already changed my mind and given up the whole idea. I stayed at home, until your forces came and arrested me."
“我决定我不打算做了。他们对我非常愤怒。他们一路冲我吼回来。而且他们还试图派我去耶路撒冷执行另一次袭击。但我已经改变了主意，放弃了整个想法。我呆在家里，直到你们的军队来把我逮捕。”
Ben-Eliezer, "And now what?"
本-埃利泽：“那现在呢？”
Ahmed, "And now I'm here. It was a mistake. It's wrong to kill people and children. Doing something like that is forbidden. There's no way I would do it. And the fact is, I didn't do it."
艾哈迈德：“现在我在这儿。这是一个错误。杀害平民和孩子是错误的。做这种事情是被禁止的。我绝不会再做了。事实是，我没做。”
Ben-Eliezer, "If you're released, what will you do?"
本-埃利泽：“如果你被释放，你会做什么？”
Ahmed, "I'd leave this place immediately. I'd go live in Jordan with my mother. I would draw a line across the past and never come back here. Yes, I faltered. But it was a momentary stumble. That's not me. I was swept up into this thing, but I came to my senses. In Jordan, with my mother and sisters, I would continue studying. I'd get a degree at the university. I'd never go near anything like this again."
艾哈迈德：“我会立刻离开这个地方。我会去约旦和我的母亲住在一起。我会彻底告别过去，再也不回这里。是的，我动摇了。但这只是暂时的失足。那不是我。我被这件事裹挟了，但我清醒过来了。在约旦，和我的母亲及姐妹在一起，我会继续学习。我会从大学拿到学位。我再也不会靠近任何这种事了。”
At this point, Ben-Eliezer says goodbye and signals that the conversation has ended. Ahmed bursts out crying. "Please, Mr. Minister, wait a minute. There's something else I want to tell you." Ben-Eliezer turns around to listen.
此时，本-埃利泽说了再见并示意谈话结束。艾哈迈德放声大哭。“求您了，部长先生，等一下。还有别的事我想告诉您。”本-埃利泽转过身来听。
Ahmed, "I'm finished with this. I swear it. Please let me out of here. I want to ask you to transfer me to my family in Jordan."
艾哈迈德：“我受够了。我发誓。请让我离开这儿。我想求您把我转交给我住在约旦的家人。”
He listens but doesn't say anything. She sighs. "What will become of me? I have no future. I don't want my whole life to be ruined because of this. I didn't do anything. Don't forget that. I didn't do it. I changed my mind. Please let me out."
他听着，但什么也没说。她叹了口气。“我会怎么样呢？我没有未来。我不希望我整个人生因为这个而毁掉。我没做任何事。别忘了。我没做。我改变了主意。请让我出去。”
"To each his fate," Ben-Eliezer said. And then he left the room.
“各安天命吧。”本-埃利泽说完便离开了房间。
Last Thursday afternoon, in his office at the defense ministry, Ben-Eliezer said that from now on he intends to keep interviewing other potential suicide bombers, because they're the main problem that the defense establishment has to contend with. "This is an efficient, quick, cheap, and highly lethal kind of weapon that is very hard to overcome," the defense minister said. "That's why I want to meet them face-to-face."
上周四下午，在国防部办公室里，本-埃利泽表示，从现在起，他打算继续采访其他潜在的自杀式炸弹袭击者，因为他们是国防部门不得不面对的主要问题。“这是一种高效、快速、廉价且极具杀伤力的武器，非常难以克服，”国防部长说。“这就是为什么我想和他们面对面会谈。”
There are professionals in the Shin-Bet whose job it is to do this. Why was it important for you to meet them yourself?
辛贝特有专业人员专门负责此事。为什么亲自会见他们对你来说很重要？
"If I'm fighting against something, I need to get to know it personally. I know tanks and airplanes and artillery. But I don't know the person who turns himself into a bomb."
“如果我在与某件事作斗争，我需要亲自了解它。我了解坦克、飞机和火炮。但我不了解那个把自己变成炸弹的人。”
Do you think you'll learn something that you didn't know before?
你认为你会学到一些你以前不知道的东西吗？
"First of all, I wanted to have the contact. To look them in the eye. To see if they look me in the eye. To see how I would feel, to try to understand directly what causes a young man or woman in their teens to throw everything away, to go out and murder innocent people, to commit suicide. I had to sit down across from this thing."
“首先，我想建立这种接触。直视他们的眼睛。看他们是否直视我的眼睛。看看我会是什么感觉，试着直接去理解是什么导致一个十几岁的年轻人把一切都抛弃，走出去谋杀无辜者，实施自杀。我必须坐在这种东西对面。”
And what did you learn?
那你学到了什么？
"I felt different things in the meeting with him and the meeting with her. And I learned different things from both cases. The young man said he wouldn't do it again, but I didn't believe him. He recited the brainwashing they did to him, nothing more. It sounded more like someone with a weak character whom the surrounding system had homed in on, caught and trained for the assignment. He seemed like a spineless young man, nothing special."
“在与他的会面和与她的会面中，我感受到了不同的东西。我从两个案例中了解到了不同的事情。那个年轻人说他不会再做了，但我没信他。他只是在背诵他们对他洗脑的内容，仅此而已。听起来更像是一个意志薄弱的人，被周围的环境系统锁定、捕获并针对任务进行了训练。他看起来像个没骨气的年轻人，没什么特别的。”
How did the meeting with her go?
和她的会面怎么样？
"It wasn't easy. She showed emotion. She spoke, she was quiet, she smiled, she cried. She's an intelligent young woman and took part in a flowing conversation."
“并不容易。她表现出了情感。她说话、安静、微笑、哭泣。她是个聪明的年轻女性，参与了一场流畅的对话。”
How did you feel when you were sitting there facing her?
坐在她对面时你感觉如何？
"To be honest, I felt sorry for her. I admit it. I thought she was pitiable. I found it hard to fathom how a girl like her, an educated young woman with her whole future ahead of her, could have ended up in such a situation, ready to commit such an inhuman act. On the other hand, the fact that she did not go through with it and the way she expressed remorse touched me. I admit that I felt compassion for her."
“老实说，我为她感到难过。我承认。我觉得她很可怜。我发现很难理解像她这样的一个女孩，一个受过教育的年轻女性，未来一片光明，怎么会陷入这样的境地，准备实施如此非人道的行为。另一方面，她没有继续进行下去这一事实，以及她表达悔意的方式触动了我。我承认我同情她。”
What do you think ought to be done with her?
你认为应该怎么处置她？
"I don't know. And I'm not the one who has to decide. I tend to believe that if she's released she will get as far away from here as possible and try to start a new life."
“我不知道。做出决定的人不是我。我倾向于相信，如果她被释放，她会尽可能远离这里，尝试开始新的生活。”
Isn't there something unseemly about a defense minister choosing to sit down with someone who almost killed innocent civilians and giving her a platform, and then even feeling such empathy towards her?
国防部长选择坐下来与一个差点杀死无辜平民的人交谈，并为她提供一个平台，甚至对她产生同情，这难道没有不妥之处吗？
"Listen well. This meeting was held in the context of know thine enemy. None of the rest interests me. To me, this is an important meeting that is supplying valuable information."
“听好。这次会面是在‘知己知彼’的背景下进行的。除此之外的其他事情我不感兴趣。对我来说，这是一次重要的会面，它提供了有价值的信息。”
She was just a hairbreadth away from blowing herself up and killing innocent Israeli civilians.
她离引爆炸弹杀害无辜的以色列平民仅有一线之隔。
"True, and you don't have to remind me of that. I haven't forgotten that for a moment. But then she tells you her life story, and smiles and cries, and you remember that this is a 20-year-old girl. And you also feel sorry for her. My gut feeling was that she was telling the truth. She almost did a monstrous thing, but in the end she didn't. Of course, I haven't changed my opinion about the severity of the phenomenon or the severity of the fact that she was a willing participant in it until the very last moment. And she also didn't prevent the terror attack. But she did manage to move me."
“确实，你没必要提醒我。我一刻也没忘记。但当她告诉你她的人生故事，又哭又笑时，你记住了这是一个20岁的女孩。你也会为她感到难过。我的直觉是她在说实话。她差点做了一件骇人听闻的事，但最终她没做。当然，我关于这一现象的严重性，以及她在最后一刻之前一直是一个愿意参与者的事实，这些看法并没有改变。而且她也没能阻止那次恐怖袭击。但她确实打动了我。”
What new and relevant information did this meeting provide?
这次会面提供了哪些新的相关信息？
"There is an entire system that operates to produce human bombs. Here you can see how this machine works. As soon as she said she wanted to commit suicide, the whole thing took on a tremendous momentum and went totally out of her control. Here you have a girl who suddenly blurted something out. I'm almost certain that she, herself, didn't really mean it. But as soon as the words were said, they pounced on her. They came at her from every direction."
“有一个完整的系统在运作，以生产人肉炸弹。在这里你可以看到这台机器是如何运作的。当她说她想自杀时，整件事就产生了巨大的惯性，完全超出了她的控制。你眼前的这个女孩突然脱口而出。我几乎肯定，她自己并没有真正打算那么做。但一旦话出口，他们就扑向了她。他们从各个方向围攻她。”
And how does all this insight and analysis help us? The terror attacks are continuing all the time.
所有这些见解和分析对我们有什么帮助呢？恐怖袭击一直在持续。
"86% of terror attacks are foiled and prevented. Understanding the enemy is always helpful, knowing the behind-the-scenes mechanisms. We are interested in the moment that comes before. I have a lot of information on the table. My objective is to prevent suicide bombings. That's what Operation Defensive Shield was for. That's what all the other operations are for. But unfortunately, while the Israeli Defense Forces are carrying out these necessary actions, the operations themselves become a hothouse that produces more and more new suicide bombers. The military actions kindle the frustration, hatred, and despair, and are the incubator for the terror to come. The religious and political environment immediately exploits this effect and dispatches the new suicide bombers. And the pattern is repeated."
“86%的恐怖袭击被挫败和预防了。了解敌人总是有帮助的，知道其幕后机制。我们关注的是那一刻之前发生的事。我手头有很多信息。我的目标是预防自杀式炸弹袭击。这就是‘防御之盾行动’的目的。这也是所有其他行动的目的。但不幸的是，当以色列国防军执行这些必要的行动时，这些行动本身成了一个孵化器，产生了越来越多的新自杀式炸弹袭击者。军事行动点燃了挫败感、仇恨和绝望，成为了恐怖活动滋生的温床。宗教和政治环境立即利用这种效应，派遣新的自杀式炸弹袭击者。就这样，模式不断循环。”
You are the defense minister of the state of Israel, and you're basically saying that we're trapped in an endless, vicious circle, that there's no solution, that we have no horizon to look toward and no hope that this terrible situation will end.
你是以色列国防部长，你基本上是在说我们陷入了一个无休止、恶性的循环，没有解决方案，我们没有任何可以展望的视野，也没有这个可怕的情况会结束的希望。
"It is a terribly vicious and evil circle, but I do see hope. With Yasser Arafat, it won't happen. It will happen with someone else. As soon as the Palestinians have a new dream of a truly better life, of a normal life, the whole bit about the virgins in Paradise and all the other nonsense they've sold them will lose its magic. I believe that then, young people like Arin Ahmed and even Rasan Stiti will say no to anyone who tries to convince them to choose death over life."
“这是一个极其恶毒的循环，但我确实看到了希望。有亚西尔·阿拉法特在，就不会结束。换一个人就会变。一旦巴勒斯坦人有了真正美好生活的梦想，有了正常生活的梦想，他们被兜售的那些关于天堂里的处女之类的废话就会失去魔力。我相信到那时，像阿琳·艾哈迈德甚至拉桑·斯蒂蒂这样的年轻人，会对任何试图说服他们选择死亡而非生命的人说不。”
Actress Enid Graham, reading a story from the Israeli newspaper Ha'aretz from June 2002. If you like this kind of coverage of the Mideast conflict, Ha'aretz's English-language website is haaretzdaily.com. In all, about a dozen suicide bombers met with the defense minister, according to the ministry.
女演员伊妮德·格雷厄姆朗读了2002年6月以色列《国土报》的一篇报道。如果你喜欢这种对中东冲突的报道，《国土报》的英文网站是haaretzdaily.com。据国防部称，总共有大约十几名自杀式炸弹袭击者与国防部长进行了会面。
Coming up, Jello and a marshmallow sit down together and talk. That's going to make a lot more sense in about five minutes, OK? From Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来的节目，杰洛和一个棉花糖将坐在一起谈谈。五分钟后，这听起来会更有意义，好吗？来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，我们的节目继续播出。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week, of course, on our program we choose a theme and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, Know Your Enemy, the stories of people getting to know the people that they are fighting and how complicated that can be. We have arrived at Act Two of our program, another act in which two adversaries have a rare face-to-face meeting. Act Two, I Am Curious, Jello.
这里是《此美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，每周我们的节目都会选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目主题是：了解你的敌人，讲述人们了解他们正在与之战斗的人，以及这可能有多复杂的故事。我们进入了节目的第二幕，这是另一幕，其中两位对手进行了一次罕见的面对面会面。第二幕：我很好奇，杰洛。
This is the story of a guy who gets to understand his enemy, but way too late to do him any good at all. It starts in 1986, when Michael Guarino is the latest hire at something called the Special Operations Division of the LA District Attorney's office. It's a prestigious job, a chance to try high-profile cases about a fairly juicy subject, obscenity. Guarino is just 38-- young compared to the rest of his colleagues-- and he is about to file charges that are going to make headlines around the world. David Segal tells what happened.
这是一个男人最终理解了他的敌人的故事，但已经太迟了，对他一点帮助也没有。故事始于1986年，当时迈克尔·瓜里诺刚刚入职洛杉矶地方检察官办公室的特别行动处。这是一份令人羡慕的工作，有机会审理涉及相当引人注目的主题——淫秽——的高调案件。瓜里诺才38岁——与同事相比很年轻——并且他即将提起一项将登上世界各地头条新闻的指控。大卫·西格尔讲述了发生的事情。
There's an old joke that sums up this whole story in a punch line. Be warned, it's a little off-color. It's about a guy complaining in a bar about how he is remembered. "I served in the House of Representatives for 10 years," he says, "but does anyone call me Mr. Congressman? No, sir. I ran a corner store for a decade, but does anyone call me Mr. Grocer? No, they don't. I owned a farm for a long, long time, and harvested wheat, raised cattle. Does anyone call me Mr. Farmer? Nope. You [BEEP] one sheep."
有一个老笑话总结了整个故事的笑点。提醒一下，它有点不雅。讲的是一个在酒吧里抱怨别人如何记住他的男人。“我在众议院任职了10年，”他说，“但有人称我为国会议员先生吗？没有。我经营了一家街角杂货店十年，但有人称我为杂货店主先生吗？没有。我拥有一家农场很长很长一段时间，收获小麦，养牛。有人称我为农场主先生吗？没有。你操了一只羊……”
Thank you. Enjoy your salads. I'll be here all week.
谢谢。享受你们的沙拉吧。我会在这里待上一整周。
OK, it's a little crude. But it gets us to this question you probably never thought you'd hear. How do you un-[BEEP] a sheep? What do you do if you're remembered for one of the worst moments in your life for years, even if that person is no longer really you? Michael Guarino has confronted this very matter-- minus the sheep, of course-- for a while.
好吧，这有点粗俗。但这让我们想到了这个你可能从未想过的问题。你怎么取消“操”羊的事实？如果你因为人生中最糟糕的时刻之一而被铭记多年，即使那个人其实已经不再是你了，你该怎么办？迈克尔·瓜里诺在一段时间里一直面对着这件事——当然，撇开那只羊不谈。
We start at the height of the Reagan era culture wars. Tipper Gore is pushing warning labels on albums by bands like Judas Priest and Twisted Sister. The punk rock band called Dead Kennedys has released an album called Frankenchrist. And included in every copy is a poster by a Swiss artist named H. R. Giger. You know Giger's work even if you don't recognize his name, because he designed the look of the great sci-fi monster movie, Alien , which earned him an Academy Award. But the Giger poster in this album would never earn a PG rating. I'd love to describe it, but current broadcasting standards make that risky. The title of the painting says everything you need to know-- Penis Landscape. Let's just move on.
我们从里根时代的文化战争高潮开始。蒂珀·戈尔正在推动在犹大祭司和扭曲姐妹等乐队的专辑上贴上警告标签。一支名为“死肯尼迪”的朋克摇滚乐队发行了一张名为《弗兰肯基督》的专辑。每一份专辑里都包含一张瑞士艺术家H.R.吉格的海报。你肯定知道吉格的作品，即使你记不住他的名字，因为他设计了伟大的科幻怪物电影《异形》的形象，这为他赢得了奥斯卡奖。但这张专辑里的吉格海报绝对拿不到PG评级。我很乐意描述它，但当前的广播标准使这变得冒险。画作的标题说明了你需要知道的一切——《阴茎景观》。我们直接跳过吧。
Guarino gets a copy of Penis Landscape , and he thinks he has the grounds for an obscenity charge.
瓜里诺拿到了《阴茎景观》的副本，他认为自己有理由提起淫秽指控。
I remember looking at the piece of art and thinking, just on the basis of the insert, that we had a great case. It seemed to me that that is the kind of material that most adults wouldn't want to see distributed to kids.
我记得看着那件艺术品，心想，仅凭这张内页，我们就有一个绝佳的案件。在我看来，这是大多数成年人不会想让孩子看到的传播材料。
Dead Kennedys, for those who don't know, were a big deal in the world of punk rock, one of the most popular American acts the genre ever produced. The band's music ran, for the most part, at the speed of a blender on puree. And the lyrics-- written by singer and songwriter Jello Biafra-- were strongly anti-government, to the point of paranoia. They had a song called "Government Flu" about an imagined attempt by the US to poison its own citizens. Another tune called "California Uber Alles" compared former governor Jerry Brown to Hitler.
“死肯尼迪”，对于不知道的人来说，是朋克摇滚世界里的大事，是该流派产生过的最受欢迎的美国乐队之一。这支乐队的音乐，大部分是以搅拌机在纯泥模式下的速度运行的。而由歌手兼词曲作者杰洛·比阿弗拉创作的歌词——具有强烈的反政府色彩，到了偏执的程度。他们有一首歌叫《政府流感》，关于美国蓄意毒害本国公民的想象。另一首歌叫《加利福尼亚之上》，将前州长杰里·布朗与希特勒进行了比较。
[MUSIC -- "CALIFORNIA UBER ALLES" BY THE DEAD KENNEDYS]
[音乐——《加利福尼亚之上》，死肯尼迪乐队]
Guarino ordered up an investigation, and soon after, nine cops were busting into the apartment of Jello Biafra. This was the sort of case that could make a young prosecutor's name, and Guarino made the most of it. During the year and a half it took to get this matter into court, he was quoted in places like the New York Times , and he was soon famous enough to be denounced by Frank Zappa.
瓜里诺下令进行调查，不久之后，九名警察闯进了杰洛·比阿弗拉的公寓。这是一起可以成就年轻检察官名声的案件，瓜里诺充分利用了这一点。在将此事送上法庭的一年半时间里，他在《纽约时报》等报刊上被引用，很快就出名到被弗兰克·扎帕公开谴责。
He wanted to set a precedent. And he was on a winning streak-- 30 victories in a row-- which made him a little cocky. He never bothered to research the Dead Kennedys. And when a colleague suggested he might want to listen to the Frankenchrist album, he ignored her. He believed in what he was doing. The law seemed utterly clear to him. And he was in love with the righteousness of his cause. At one point, he actually compared Jello Biafra to a serial murderer named Richard Ramirez, who was convicted of killing 13 people.
他想开创一个先例。而且他一直处于连胜状态——连续30次胜利——这让他有点自负。他从没费心去研究“死肯尼迪”。当一位同事建议他也许该听听《弗兰肯基督》专辑时，他无视了她。他相信自己在做的事。法律对他来说完全清晰明了。他沉迷于他事业的正义感中。有一次，他竟然把杰洛·比阿弗拉比作一个名叫理查德·拉米雷斯的连环杀手，后者因杀害13人而被定罪。
But as soon as the trial began, Guarino realized that he would have to fight for the moral high ground. He was up against Phil Schnayerson, a very expensive and widely-admired defense lawyer who decided to take Jello's case for free. Schnayerson had a mastery of the arguments and a sense of humor. Even when Phil was interviewing prospective jurors, it seemed to Guarino he was charming the room.
但审判一开始，瓜里诺就意识到他必须为道德高地而战。他的对手是菲尔·施纳森，一位非常昂贵且广受赞誉的辩护律师，他决定免费接手杰洛的案子。施纳森掌握了辩论技巧，而且很有幽默感。即使菲尔在面试潜在的陪审员时，瓜里诺也觉得他在吸引整个法庭。
He seemed to be having a whole lot of fun with the trial, way more fun than I was having with it. And he seemed to feel like he was on the right side. And that's not usual, for a prosecutor to be involved in a case in which the defense attorney has this feeling of righteousness. That's supposed to be mine. That's supposed to be my territory. And so it was upsetting to see him so sure of himself, and so sure of the merits of his case. And I could start reading the jurors. I pride myself on being able to see what's on the jurors' minds, really almost within 10 seconds of their starting to answer questions. And I didn't like what I was seeing. I was seeing a lot of various degrees of hatred for me registering on faces. So I started getting the feeling that this was not a great case very early on in the trial.
他似乎在审判中玩得很开心，比我玩得开心多了。而且他似乎觉得自己站在正确的一边。这对于检察官来说并不常见，参与一个辩方律师有这种正义感的案件。那是我的领地。那是我的地盘。所以看到他那么确信自己，那么确信案件的是非曲直，真让人心烦。我开始能读懂陪审员了。我以能看出陪审员在想什么而自豪，基本上在他们开始回答问题的10秒内就能看出来。我没喜欢我所看到的。我在陪审员脸上看到了不同程度的仇恨。所以我在审判的很早就开始觉得这案子不妙了。
But Guarino had a Perry Mason moment in mind that he thought was a killer.
但瓜里诺心中有一个佩里·梅森式的时刻，他认为那是一记必杀技。
You know, every prosecutor wants to present the critical evidence in a dramatic way. And I wanted the poster introduced by the mother of the child who had purchased the album. "Let's get Mary Sierra to the stand." And then she would lay the foundation for this poster. I'd ask her if this is similar to the poster that she saw in the album that her son had purchased. She would say, yes. And then at that point, I would have it marked as an exhibit, and I-- not Phil, but I-- would then show it to the jury. And it would be the moment that I chose, rather than the moment that Phil chose.
你知道，每个检察官都想以戏剧性的方式呈现关键证据。我希望这张海报是由购买这张专辑的孩子的母亲提交的。“让玛丽·塞拉上台。”然后她将为这张海报奠定基础。我会问她这是否类似于她儿子购买的专辑中看到的海报。她会说是。然后在那个时刻，我会把它标记为展品，我会——不是菲尔，而是我——向陪审团展示它。那将是我选择的时刻，而不是菲尔选择的时刻。
And instead of that happening, Phil, on his first question-- I mean it was like his first question out of the box. All of a sudden, Phil is passing this poster out to the jurors. And they're looking at it. And they are getting used to it. And he said, this is a poster that's ugly and it's offensive. But you're going to have to decide whether or not it's obscene.
但结果却是，菲尔在第一个问题上——我的意思是就像他开箱后的第一个问题。突然，菲尔把这张海报传给了陪审员。他们在看它。他们正在习惯它。他说，这张海报很丑，很冒犯人。但你们将不得不决定它是否淫秽。
The jury survived their peek at Penis Landscape , and then Schnayerson played them some Dead Kennedys songs. The band's lyrics, it was soon obvious, were blunt but surprisingly sophisticated. To the jury, and to Guarino-- who of course had never heard the band until he got to court-- the Giger poster now had some context to put it in a very different light. The defense called professors and music critics to the stand, and the trial became an art and history lesson instead of a discourse about protecting the children.
陪审团挺过了对《阴茎景观》的审视，然后施纳森给他们播放了一些“死肯尼迪”的歌曲。很快大家就很清楚了，乐队的歌词虽然生硬，但出奇地复杂。对陪审团来说，以及对瓜里诺来说——他当然在到达法庭之前从没听过这个乐队——这张吉格海报现在有了背景，可以从完全不同的角度看待它。辩方传唤了教授和音乐评论家上台，审判变成了一场关于艺术和历史的课程，而不是一场关于保护儿童的辩论。
[MUSIC -- "GOVERNMENT FLU" BY THE DEAD KENNEDYS]
[音乐——《政府流感》，死肯尼迪乐队]
There's the way you tell the story of your life, and if you're lucky, your version is the best known. If you're not so lucky, some opponent defines your legacy for you. And if you're really unlucky, that opponent is Jello Biafra.
讲述你自己人生的方式有很多种，如果你幸运的话，你的版本是最著名的。如果你没那么幸运，某个对手会为你定义你的遗产。如果你真的很不幸，那个对手就是杰洛·比阿弗拉。
All right. Isn't this painting sick? Isn't this painting obscene? Isn't this painting sick? Don't you think Giger is obsessed with sex with the dead? Isn't this painting sexually explicit? Isn't this sick? Isn't this sick?
“好吧。这幅画不病态吗？这幅画不淫秽吗？这幅画不病态吗？你不觉得吉格沉迷于与死者做爱吗？这幅画在性方面不显露吗？这不病态吗？这不病态吗？”
This is Jello, from a spoken-word account of the trial on an album called The High Priest of Harmful Matter. He toured with this material, and got a lot of attention and press for it. If Guarino's mistake was that he didn't really know and understand his enemy, he was up against a foe who is an amazingly close observer of people. And throughout the 44-minute monologue, Jello does a withering impersonation of Guarino, who comes across in great detail as a moralizing bozo.
这是杰洛，摘自他在一张名为《有害物质大祭司》的专辑中对审判的口述记录。他带着这些材料巡回演出，并因此获得了大量的关注和报道。如果瓜里诺的错误在于他没有真正了解和理解他的敌人，那么他的对手就是一个对人观察入微的人。在44分钟的独白中，杰洛对瓜里诺进行了冷嘲热讽的模仿，在细节中展现了他是一个道德说教的笨蛋。
I can't imitate Michael Guarino properly without a pen open and cocked between the index and middle finger, always kind of poking at you right at eye level when he talks to you, kind of like a little claw or something. Poking at you with his pen.
如果不把钢笔夹在食指和中指之间打开并扣住，我就无法正确模仿迈克尔·瓜里诺。当他跟你说话时，它总是像个小爪子一样在你的视线水平位置戳来戳去。用钢笔戳你。
And here's Jello doing Guarino talking to the jury.
这是杰洛在模仿瓜里诺对陪审团讲话。
"Don't be fooled by the fact that Mr. Jello Biafra appears to be nicely dressed or smiling [? benignly ?] over here. And don't be fooled by the fact that their lawyers appear to be friendlier than I am."
“不要被杰洛·比阿弗拉先生看起来穿着得体或在这里（ benignly？）微笑着的事实所愚弄。不要被他们的律师看起来比我更友好的事实所愚弄。”
Finally, he couldn't restrain himself. He had to do it anyway. He whips out the Giger poster and flails it around the courtroom for all to see, thus exposing its contents to at least 15 minors in the courtroom gallery.
最后，他控制不住自己了。他还是得那么做。他掏出吉格的海报，在法庭上挥舞着让所有人看，从而将里面的内容暴露给了法庭画廊里的至少15名未成年人。
By the time Guarino is waving that poster around, just about everything that could go wrong for him had gone wrong, so wrong that even he didn't believe his arguments anymore. Just as bad, the guy who was supposed to be cast as the villain, Jello, was coming across like the reasonable one.
当瓜里诺挥舞着那张海报时，几乎所有可能出问题的事情都出错了，错到连他自己都不再相信自己的论点了。同样糟糕的是，那个本该被塑造成恶棍的人，杰洛，反而显得像个理性的人。
Remember, this was big news, the test case in the '80s culture wars. In the international coverage of the trial, and in reports in newspapers and on television, it was clear that Biafra wasn't the only one who found the whole thing a little ridiculous.
记住，这可是大新闻，是80年代文化战争的测试案例。在对这次审判的国际报道中，以及报纸和电视的报道中，很明显，比阿弗拉并不是唯一一个觉得整件事有点荒谬的人。
Well, all throughout the trial we were seeing various anchors kind of smirking at the fact that we were doing this. That was unusual. That was different. I hadn't experienced that yet. But that was-- I did start to think that I was on, not the wrong side of the case so much, but more generally the wrong side of history. I just felt I was on the wrong side of history.
嗯，在整个审判过程中，我们看到很多主播对我们在做这件事感到暗自窃笑。那是不寻常的。那是不同的。我以前还没经历过那种事。但我开始认为我所处的，与其说是在案件的错误一边，不如说是在更普遍的历史错误一边。我只是觉得我站在了历史错误的一边。
He was right. In the end, the jury deadlocked, with the majority for acquittal. Guarino requested a retrial, but the judge would have none of it. Case dismissed.
他是对的。最后，陪审团陷入僵局，多数人赞成无罪释放。瓜里诺申请重审，但法官根本不同意。案件驳回。
This trial was the start of a pretty radical transformation for Michael Guarino. After that case, and a few more like it, the priorities of the DA's office started to bug him. There were all these show trials that added up to nothing, and all sorts of crimes-- corporate crimes, political conflicts of interest-- that were just ignored. He feuded with his boss, James Hahn, then became so exasperated that he tried to throw the guy out of office by running against him for the district attorney's job. He lost that election. Hahn is now the mayor of Los Angeles by the way.
这次审判是迈克尔·瓜里诺彻底转型的一个开始。在那之后，以及类似的其他案件之后，地方检察官办公室的优先级开始让他感到困扰。全是一些一无所获的作秀案件，以及各种各样的犯罪——企业犯罪、政治利益冲突——都被忽视了。他与上司詹姆斯·哈恩发生争执，随后变得如此愤怒，以至于他通过竞选地方检察官的职位试图把那个家伙赶下台。他在那次选举中输了。顺便说一下，哈恩现在是洛杉矶市长。
Guarino left the city, and wound up as the dean of a small law school in northern California. The whole idea of being a prosecutor and doing anything to take an opponent down didn't appeal to him anymore. He was more interested in cases coming out fairly. And once a prosecutor is more interested in fairness than in winning, he's pretty much not doing his job.
瓜里诺离开了这座城市，最终成为了加利福尼亚北部一所小型法学院的院长。当检察官并不惜一切代价去摧毁对手的念头不再吸引他了。他更关心案件得到公平处理。一旦检察官对公平的兴趣超过了获胜的兴趣，他基本上就没法再做好他的工作了。
So in a sense, this trial kind of snapped you out of it, the substance of it began to matter more.
所以从某种意义上说，这次审判让你摆脱了那种状态，案件的实质内容开始变得更重要。
Yeah, I hate to say yes to that, but that's actually a pretty accurate assessment. If I look back, I would say that that was a turning point for me.
是的，我不想说同意，但这确实是一个相当准确的评估。如果我回顾过去，我会说那是我人生的一个转折点。
He was a different guy, but nobody knew it. He couldn't escape his most famous case. For one thing, his students remembered.
他已经变成了一个不同的人，但没人知道。他无法逃避他最著名的案件。首先，他的学生们记得。
From time to time, someone would come up to me and say, are you the Mike Guarino that prosecuted Jello Biafra? What were you thinking? And students were amazed that this person that they thought they knew had been involved in this thing. I think they were kind of hoping I'd say that was a different Michael Guarino.
时不时地，会有人走过来对我说，你是那个起诉杰洛·比阿弗拉的迈克·瓜里诺吗？你当时在想什么？学生们很惊讶，他们认为自己认识的这个人竟然参与了那件事。我想他们是希望我能说那是另一个迈克尔·瓜里诺。
And if that wasn't bad enough, his son, for reasons we can only guess at, turned into a huge fan of Jello Biafra, and at home, he was forced to listen to Dead Kennedys music for years.
如果那还不够糟糕的话，他的儿子——出于我们只能猜测的原因——变成了一个杰洛·比阿弗拉的铁杆粉丝，在家里，他被迫听了多年的“死肯尼迪”音乐。
The old version of Guarino, the one parodied by Jello, has pretty much vanished from the world. Jello has never met the new Guarino and, given the hand that Jello had in defining the old one, we decided it was time for an introduction.
旧版本的瓜里诺，那个被杰洛戏仿的瓜里诺，已经从这个世界上消失了。杰洛从未见过新版本的瓜里诺，鉴于杰洛在定义那个旧版本中的作用，我们决定是时候做个介绍了。
I hear ringing.
我听到铃声了。
Hello?
喂？
Jello Biafra is on the line with me.
杰洛·比阿弗拉和我在线上。
Hello.
喂。
Hello, Jello.
你好，杰洛。
Hi.
嗨。
How are you?
你好吗？
OK.
还可以。
Good.
很好。
Did you guys ever get a chance to talk?
你们俩有机会聊过吗？
I don't think-- I think our only conversation was right after the trial.
我不认为——我想我们唯一的谈话是在审判刚结束之后。
When you handed me the album. I remember that.
当你把专辑递给我的时候。我记得那个。
Yeah, I held up the insert from an extended-play recording by a band called Big Black, called Headache , that had a pathology photo of somebody's head was split open inside, thinking, if you think the Giger painting is offensive, wait till you see this.
是的，我举起了Big Black乐队名为《头痛》的加长唱片中的内页，上面有一张某人头部裂开的病理照片，想着，如果你觉得吉格的画冒犯了你，等你看到这个再说。
Yes, I thought that was really sweet of you to do. I remember--
是的，我觉得你这么做真是太贴心了。我记得——
I think you said, don't be a bad winner. I took that very seriously, and I thought you had a point on that. And then the elevator doors closed. And away I went.
我想你说，别做个糟糕的赢家。我非常认真地对待了这一点，我想你当时说得有道理。然后电梯门关上了。我就走了。
Years ago, Jello heard that Michael regretted the case. And Jello wasn't angry at him anymore. So this became a heart-to-heart conversation pretty quickly.
几年前，杰洛听说迈克尔对那个案子感到后悔。杰洛不再生他的气了。所以这很快变成了一次推心置腹的谈话。
--and she said, well, I think it was, you probably had a little bit-- maybe more than a little bit-- to do with my changing my mind about what the priorities ought to be at the City Attorney's Office. And I remember that you said in some interview, Jello, that I seemed so pure. I was trying to look out for-- I thought I was looking out for the youth of America. And I knew the exact degree of sarcasm-- Then I think I did a little soul-searching after that trial. So it was all for the good, really.
——她说，嗯，我想是因为，你可能在某种程度上——也许不仅仅是某种程度上——与我改变对市检察官办公室优先事项的看法有关。我记得你在某次采访中说过，杰洛，我看起来那么纯洁。我当时试图照顾——我以为我在照顾美国的青年。我准确地知道了那种讽刺的程度——然后我想在那次审判后我做了一次灵魂深处的反思。所以，这真的是一件好事。
Well, what I'm getting out of all of this today is Mr. Guarino crediting me with being, long-term, a positive influence on his life. And I never would have guessed that that could have happened. And that makes it all the more worthwhile to keep causing trouble the way I do. I mean it always--
好吧，我今天从这一切中得到的结论是，瓜里诺先生归功于我在长期看来对他的人生有积极的影响。我从来没猜到会发生这种情况。这让我觉得继续像我这样做这种捣乱的事更加值得。我的意思是它总是——
After a few minutes, these two were talking like old war buddies. Then they were just talking. And then it was hard to get a word in edgewise. They reminisced about the trial.
几分钟后，这两个人谈话就像老战友一样。然后他们就在聊天。然后就很难插进话了。他们回忆起那次审判。
--I mean at the time, you came across quite zealous.
——我的意思是当时你看起来非常热衷。
Is that a compliment?
那是恭维吗？
They cleared up a few nagging questions.
他们澄清了一些令人烦恼的问题。
Why was it necessary for Detective Carter to lie on the witness stand about a point that didn't really even matter?
为什么卡特侦探必须在证人席上就一个甚至完全不重要的问题撒谎？
They talked politics-- Al Gore, 2000 elections.
他们谈论了政治——阿尔·戈尔，2000年大选。
Yeah, he did win.
是的，他确实赢了。
He did win. Yeah.
他确实赢了。是的。
Let me get us back to our subject.
让我带回我们的主题。
Sure.
当然。
He didn't even question--
他甚至没有质疑——
These two guys, who were at war for a year and a half, were actually bonding. Politically, they were on the same page. And it was a page where you don't find a lot of Americans these days.
这两个曾经战斗了一年半的家伙，实际上正在建立友谊。在政治上，他们立场一致。那是一个你现在在美国找不到多少人的页面。
And I'm hoping that they'll see the similarities between Bush and Mussolini, frankly, because--
而且我希望他们能看到布什和墨索里尼之间的相似之处，坦率地说，因为——
Well, the one who's the most like Mussolini is Schwarzenegger.
嗯，最像墨索里尼的人是施瓦辛格。
Can I interrupt you and just say it's kind of hard to imagine that you guys ever were adversaries.
我可以打断你一下，说很难想象你们俩竟然是对手。
I have a good feeling about Jello. I don't think you can fake fondness. And I know I can't. If I'm not fond of somebody, people can tell it pretty fast.
我对杰洛有很好的感觉。我不认为你可以假装亲近。我知道我不能。如果我不喜欢某个人，人们很快就能看出来。
Yep.
是啊。
But I'm fond of Jello. I think he's a good guy.
但我喜欢杰洛。我觉得他是个好人。
Jello? Would you like to share?
杰洛？你想分享一下吗？
Well, thank you. I don't know what else to say on that. I think I said earlier, I forgave Mr. Guarino a long time ago for his role in the original prosecution. And I've learned over the years that people do change. And sometimes it can be very interesting to get to know people who in earlier times may have tormented you.
嗯，谢谢。我不知道还能说什么。我想我之前说过，我很久以前就原谅了瓜里诺先生在最初起诉中的角色。而且我这些年了解到人确实会变。有时了解那些在早先时候可能折磨过你的人会非常有趣。
They talked for over an hour. By the end, these two were exchanging phone numbers. They were planning to go to dinner together, along with Guarino's son.
他们聊了一个多小时。最后，这两个人交换了电话号码。他们计划一起去吃晚饭，还要带上瓜里诺的儿子。
My son is probably one of your biggest fans.
我儿子可能是你最大的粉丝之一。
How old is he now?
他现在多大了？
He's 22.
他22岁。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, he's 22 years old. And he would play your stuff so loud that half the block could hear it.
是的，他22岁了。他会把你的东西放得很大声，半条街都能听到。
I think I did that with The Stooges, when I was a kid.
我小时候听“丑角”乐队的时候，我想我也那么干过。
Well, he was just a huge fan.
嗯，他真的是个铁杆粉丝。
When you know your enemy and your enemy knows you, it's sometimes hard to stay enemies. And yes, the ill-fated prosecution of Jello Biafra will probably make it into Michael Guarino's obituary, if it's not actually in the headline. But at this point, Guarino can't be bothered to care that much. The people who know him know he's changed, and most important, his adversary knows he's changed. To put this in sheep terms, the lamb can lie down with the lion if the lion has turned himself into a lamb. Or put another way-- one that doesn't appear in the Bible-- maybe you can un-[BEEP] a sheep. It just takes longer for word of that to get around.
当你了解你的敌人，而敌人也了解你时，有时很难保持敌对状态。是的，那场注定失败的起诉杰洛·比阿弗拉的案件可能会进入迈克尔·瓜里诺的讣告，如果它不在标题里的话。但在这一点上，瓜里诺已经不在乎那么多了。认识他的人知道他变了，最重要的是，他的对手知道他变了。用羊的术语来说，如果狮子把自己变成了羊，那么羊就可以和狮子躺在一起。或者换个说法——一个圣经里没有的说法——也许你可以取消“操”羊的事实。这只是需要更长的时间让消息传开而已。
When he's not here on the radio trying to get predators and prey to sit down together and make nice, David Segal is a reporter for the Washington Post .
当大卫·西格尔不在这里广播里试图让掠食者和猎物坐在一起和睦相处时，他是一名《华盛顿邮报》的记者。
[MUSIC - "I FOUGHT THE LAW," DEAD KENNEDYS]
[音乐——《我抗争过法律》，死肯尼迪乐队]
Act Three, Eight Percent of Nothing. Well we end our program today with a story about what it means to know your enemy in a more domestic setting, namely within a marriage. The story is by Etgar Keret, read for us by Matt Malloy.
第三幕：百分之八的虚无。好吧，我们今天以一个关于在更家庭化的环境中了解你的敌人意味着什么的故事结束我们的节目，即在婚姻内部。这个故事由埃特加·克雷特创作，由马特·马洛伊为我们朗读。
Benny Brokerage had been waiting for them in the doorway for almost half an hour. And when they arrived he tried to act as if it didn't make him mad.
本尼房产经纪已经在门口等了他们快半个小时了。当他们到达时，他试图表现得好像这并没有让他生气。
"It's all her fault," the old man sniggered, and held out his hand for a firm, no-nonsense shake.
“都是她的错，”老人窃笑着，伸出手进行了一次坚定、干脆利落的握手。
"Don't believe Butchie," the peroxide urged him. She looked at least 15 years younger than her man. "We got here earlier, except we couldn't find any parking." And Benny Brokerage gave her his foxy smile, like he really gave a damn why she and Butchie were late.
“别相信布奇，”过氧化物女郎催促他。她看起来比她的男人年轻至少15岁。“我们早就到了，只是找不到停车位。”本尼经纪给了她一个狡黠的微笑，好像他真的在乎她和布奇为什么迟到一样。
He showed them the apartment, which was almost completely furnished with a high ceiling and a kitchen window that almost gave you a view of the sea. He had barely gotten through half the usual round when Butchie pulled out his checkbook and said he'd take it, and that he was even OK with paying a year's rent upfront, except that he wanted a bit off the top, just to feel like he wasn't being taken for a ride. Benny Brokerage explained that the owner was living abroad, so he wasn't at liberty to lower the price. Butchie insisted it was small change.
他带他们看了这间公寓，公寓几乎家具齐全，有高天花板和一个几乎能让你看到大海的厨房窗户。他还没讲完一半的常规流程，布奇就拿出支票簿说他要租下它，而且即使提前支付一年的房租也没问题，只是他想在佣金上少一点，仅仅为了感觉自己没有被宰。本尼经纪解释说房主住在国外，所以他无权降低价格。布奇坚持说那是小钱。
"As far as I'm concerned," he said, "you can take it off your commission. What's your cut?"
“就我而言，”他说，“你可以从你的佣金里扣除。你的分成是多少？”
"Eight," Benny Brokerage said after a moment's pause, preferring not to risk a lie.
“八，”本尼经纪犹豫了片刻后说道，他不想冒撒谎的风险。
"So you'll still be left with five," Butchie announced, and finished writing out the check. When he saw that the broker wasn't holding out his hand to take it, he added, "Look at it this way. The market's in the cellar. And 5% of something's a lot more than 8% of nothing."
“所以你还是会有五个剩下，”布奇宣布，并写完了支票。当他看到经纪没有伸手去接时，他补充说：“换个角度看。市场正处于低谷。百分之五的某物总比百分之八的虚无要多得多。”
Butchie, or Tuvia Minster, which was the name that appeared on the check, said the peroxide would drop by the next morning to pick up an extra key. Benny Brokerage said, no problem, except that it had to be before 11:00, because he had some appointments after that. The next day, she didn't show. It was 11:20 already, and Benny Brokerage, who was aching to leave but didn't really want to stand her up, pulled the check out of the drawer. It had the office phone numbers, but he preferred to avoid another tedious conversation with Butchie and went for the home number instead.
布奇，或者说图维亚·明斯特（支票上的名字），说那个过氧化物女郎会在第二天早上过来拿一把额外的钥匙。本尼经纪说没问题，只是必须在11点之前，因为他之后有约。第二天，她没出现。已经11点20分了，本尼经纪急于离开，但又不想放她鸽子，便从抽屉里拿出了支票。上面有办公室电话号码，但他更想避免与布奇进行又一次枯燥的对话，于是选择了住宅电话。
It wasn't until she answered that he remembered that he didn't even know her name, so he opted for Mrs. Minster. She somehow sounded a little less dumb on the phone, but she still couldn't remember who he was or that they'd made an appointment for that morning.
直到她接听时，他才想起他甚至不知道她的名字，所以他选择了“明斯特太太”。她在电话里的声音听起来稍微没那么笨，但她仍然记不起他是谁，或者他们定好了那天早上的预约。
Benny Brokerage kept his cool and reminded her slowly-- the way you do when you're talking to a child-- how he had met with her and her husband the day before and how they had signed for the apartment. There was no response at the other end. And when she finally asked him to describe what she looked like, he realized he'd really blown it.
本尼经纪保持冷静，慢慢地提醒她——就像你跟孩子说话时那样——他前一天是怎么和她及她丈夫见面的，以及他们是如何为公寓签字的。电话那头没有回应。当她终于问他她长什么样时，他意识到他真的搞砸了。
"The truth is," he crooned, "that I must have the wrong number. What did you say your husband's name is? That's it, then. I was looking for Nissim and Dalia. Those 411 people messed me up again. I'm really sorry. Goodbye." And he slammed the receiver down before she had a chance to answer.
“事实是，”他柔声说道，“我肯定打错电话了。你说你丈夫叫什么名字？就是这样了。我在找尼西姆和达利亚。那些查号台的人又搞砸了。真的很抱歉。再见。”他在她有机会回答之前就挂断了电话。
The peroxide arrived at the office 15 minutes later, eyes at half-mast and a face that hadn't been washed yet. "I'm sorry," she yawned. "It took me a half an hour to find a cab."
过氧化物女郎15分钟后到达办公室，眼睛半眯着，脸还没洗。“很抱歉，”她打着哈欠说。“我花了一个小时才找到出租车。”
The following morning, when he arrived at the office, there was a woman waiting outside on the sidewalk. She looked about 40, and something about the way she was dressed, about her fragrance, was so not-from-around-here that when he spoke, he instinctively went for his most genteel pronunciation. It turned out she was looking for a two or three room place. She'd prefer to buy. But she didn't rule out a rental as long as it was available right away.
第二天早上，当他到达办公室时，有一个女人在人行道上等候。她看起来大约40岁，关于她的穿着、她的香水味，有一种非常“不属于这儿”的感觉，以至于当他开口时，他本能地使用了他最文雅的发音。原来她在找一间两三居室的房子。她更想买。但她也不排除租赁，只要能立刻入住。
Benny Brokerage said he did happen to have a few nice apartments for sale, and that because the market was in a slump, they would be reasonably priced, too. He asked her how she'd found him, and she said she had looked in the Yellow Pages.
本尼经纪说他确实有几套不错的公寓出售，而且因为市场处于低迷期，它们的价格也会很合理。他问她是怎么找到他的，她说她查了黄页。
"Are you Benny?" she asked.
“你是本尼吗？”她问。
He said no, that there hadn't been a Benny for ages. "I kept the name in order not to lose the good will. I'm Michael." He smiled. "The truth is, when I'm on the job even I forget sometimes."
他说不，本尼这个人已经很久不存在了。“我保留了这个名字是为了不损失商誉。我是迈克尔。”他笑了笑。“事实是，当我工作时，连我自己有时都会忘记。”
"I'm Leah." The woman smiled back. "Leah Minster. We spoke on the phone yesterday."
“我是莉亚。”那个女人回以微笑。“莉亚·明斯特。我们昨天通过电话。”
"This is a little uncomfortable," Leah Minster said all of a sudden, out of nowhere. The first apartment had been too dark. And they were walking through the second one. Benny Brokerage tried to play dumb, and started talking about how simple it would be to renovate and stuff like that, as if she'd been referring to the apartment. "After you phoned me," Leah Minster ignored his reply, "I tried to talk it over with him. At first he lied, but then he got tired of it and confessed. That's what the apartment is for. I'm leaving him."
“这有点尴尬，”莉亚·明斯特突然没来由地说道。第一间公寓太暗了。他们正走在第二间公寓里。本尼经纪试图装傻，开始谈论装修之类的事情有多简单，好像她指的是公寓。“在你给我打电话后，”莉亚·明斯特无视了他的回答，“我试着跟他商量。起初他撒谎，但后来他厌倦了并坦白了。这就是公寓的用途。我要离开他。”
Benny Brokerage continued showing her around, thinking to himself that it was none of his business, that there was no reason for him to get uptight. "Is she young?" Leah Minster persisted. And he nodded and said, "She's not nearly as pretty as you. I hate having to say a thing like this about a client, but he's an idiot."
本尼经纪继续带她参观，心里想着这不关他的事，他没有理由感到紧张。“她年轻吗？”莉亚·明斯特坚持问。他点点头说：“她远不如你漂亮。我很讨厌对客户说这种话，但他是个白痴。”
The third apartment had better light. And when he showed her the view of the park from the bedroom window, he felt her moving closer-- not touching him exactly, but close enough. And even though she liked the apartment, she wanted him to show her another one.
第三间公寓的光线更好。当他向她展示卧室窗外的公园景色时，他感觉到她靠得更近了——并没有直接接触，但足够近。尽管她喜欢这间公寓，但她还是想让他带她看另一间。
In the car, she kept asking him all sorts of questions about the peroxide. And Benny Brokerage tried to put her down but stay kind of vague at the same time. He didn't really feel comfortable with it, but he went on because he saw it was making her happy.
在车里，她不停地问他关于那个过氧化物女郎的各种问题。本尼经纪试图打发她，同时也保持含糊不清。他对此并不觉得舒服，但他继续下去是因为他看到这让她很高兴。
Whenever they stopped talking, there was a kind of tension, especially at the stoplights. And somehow he couldn't think of anything to say the way he usually could, a little story that would take their minds off of being stuck. All he could do was stare at the traffic light and wait for it to change.
每当他们停止交谈，就会有一种紧张感，特别是在红绿灯处。他不知怎么地想不出什么话来说，像他平时那样，讲一个小故事来分散他们对被困住的注意力。他唯一能做的就是盯着交通灯等它变色。
At one of the intersections, even when the light changed, the car in front of them, a Mercedes, didn't move. Benny Brokerage slammed the horn twice and cursed the driver through the window. And when the guy in the Mercedes didn't seem to give a damn, he stormed out of the car. Turned out, there was nobody to pick a fight with, though, because the driver, who seemed at first to be dozing, didn't wake up even when Benny Brokerage nudged him.
在其中一个十字路口，即使绿灯亮了，他们前面的一辆奔驰车也没有动。本尼经纪猛按了两下喇叭，摇下车窗咒骂司机。当奔驰车里的家伙似乎根本不在乎时，他冲出了车。不过没人在那儿可以打架，因为那个司机看起来起初是在打瞌睡，即便本尼经纪推搡他，他也没有醒来。
Then the ambulance crew arrived and said it was a stroke. They searched the driver's pockets and the car, but they couldn't find any ID. And Benny Brokerage felt kind of rotten for cursing the guy without a name, and he was sorry for the mean things he had said about the peroxide too, even though that really had nothing to do with it.
然后救护人员赶到，说是中风了。他们搜了司机的口袋和车子，但没能找到任何证件。本尼经纪因为咒骂一个无名氏而感到有些糟糕，他也为自己对那个过氧化物女郎说的刻薄话感到抱歉，即使那真的和这些没关系。
Leah Minster sat beside him in the car looking pale. He drove her back to the office and made them both some coffee. "The truth is that I didn't tell him anything," she said, and took a sip of the instant. "I was lying, actually, just so you'd tell me about her. I'm sorry, but I just had to find out."
莉亚·明斯特坐在他旁边的车里，脸色苍白。他把她送回办公室，并给他们俩煮了一些咖啡。“事实是我什么都没告诉他，”她说，喝了一口速溶咖啡。“其实我是在撒谎，只是为了让你告诉我关于她的事。我很抱歉，但我必须弄清楚。”
Benny Brokerage smiled and told himself and her that there was no harm done, really, that all they had done was see a couple of apartments and some poor guy who'd dropped dead. She finished her coffee, said sorry again, and left. And Michael, who still had a few sips to go, looked around his office, a two-by-three cubicle with a window overlooking the main drag. Suddenly the place seemed so small and transparent, like the ant colony he got for his bar mitzvah a million years ago. And all the good will he had boasted about so solemnly just two hours earlier also sounded like crap. Lately it had begun bothering him that people called him Benny.
本尼经纪笑了笑，告诉自己和她，真的没造成什么伤害，他们只是看了几套公寓和一个死去的倒霉蛋。她喝完咖啡，再次道歉并离开了。迈克尔还有几口没喝完，环顾他的办公室——一个有着能看到主干道窗户的二乘三隔间。突然间这个地方看起来那么小而透明，就像他一百万年前为成人礼得到的蚂蚁农场一样。而他仅仅两小时前还庄严吹嘘的所谓商誉听起来也像废话。最近，人们叫他本尼让他感到困扰。
Matt Malloy, reading a short story by Etgar Keret which will be published here next year in a collection called The Nimrod Flipout from Farrar, Straus, and Giroux. Etgar Keret is also the author of the book, The Bus Driver Who Thought That He Was God.
马特·马洛伊，朗读埃特加·克雷特创作的短篇小说，该小说明年将在这里出版，收录在法勒、斯特劳斯和吉鲁出版社名为《尼姆罗德翻转》的合集中。埃特加·克雷特也是《自以为是上帝的巴士司机》一书的作者。
Our program was produced today by Jane Feltes and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Sarah Koenig and Lisa Pollak. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Kevin Clark.
我们的节目今天由简·费尔特斯和我制作，艾利克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、萨拉·凯尼格和丽莎·波拉克参与。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和凯文·克拉克提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Stephen Dubner's book, where we first learned about Stetson Kennedy and Superman, is called Freakonomics. It comes out in June.
史蒂芬·杜布纳的书，我们第一次在那里了解到了史特森·肯尼迪和超人，书名叫《魔鬼经济学》。它将在六月出版。
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows for absolutely free. Or you know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. They have public radio programs, best-selling books, even the New York Times , all at audible.com. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，您可以完全免费收听我们的节目。或者您知道，您可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载我们节目的音频。他们有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至《纽约时报》，都在 audible.com 上。本节目由国际公共广播电台分发。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Torey Malatia, who has a message today for everyone.
我们节目的WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，他今天给大家留了一句话。
What this country needs is a good Klux-ing.
“这个国家需要一次彻底的‘三K化’。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《此美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。